[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online when you start out you might not
know where you're going or what you're
doing or why you're carrying this red
rose with you Honda shared their new
Superbowl commercial featuring high
school versions of Tina Fey Steve Carell
and more big celebs meanwhile Henry
Cavill Instagram from physical therapy
he's rehabbing his knee and David
Arquette posted this adorable pic his
daughter Coco holding her baby bro
David's son Charlie it seems like the
Dancing with the Stars tour just started
but it is coming to an end
Val Chmerkovskiy shared this sweet snap
with Lorri Hernandez reflecting on his
time playing her quote older brother on
tour - eyes holy day
then there's Barack Obama enjoying his
post-presidency vacay rocking a
backwards cap and Heidi Klum is also
having some fun in the Sun tanning but
she didn't take her pants all the way
off but you know I'm a European German
girl and you know we like to go topless
have a little fun don't love the tan
lines
[Music]
Oh